getting back to power there's a second
part of power which is the charging
right now there are 1100 supercharger
stations
in america what is a supercharger
station well those of you that know
tesla's you know exactly what they are
there are these big charging units that
are white and red you pull up to them
and it's got very high voltage
you plug into your car and within less
than an hour within an hour
you can get about an 80 charge well
since you can go about 300 miles or more
with these cars now
go in and have a bite to eat in about 45
minutes you come out and your car is
charged
80 percent that's kind of the design
it's where they're set up
well the supercharger stations are
joined now with what's called
destination chargers
destination chargers are those small
gray boxes that you've seen
that may be at a holiday inn or at a
marriott courtyard
or at a you know amusement park or a
mall these are destinations around town
and 4 000 destination chargers 1100
superchargers about
5 000 locations in the u.s and if you
count all the outlets all the extension
cords if you will
there's about 20 000 of them which they
claim covers
99 of the us population so what tom what
are we getting to here
i think there's something hidden and
recently
he leaked a tweet mr musk did and talked
about
it's low key but yes we are working with
another auto
manufacturer to use these wait a minute
so he built
five thousand these outlets here another
thousand superchargers in europe and
asia
so basically he has built a gas station
featuring electricity so
if you're not paying attention there are
people they're going to take their
credit card
put it on an account and they're going
to fill up their gm
or their toyota or their nissan
electric their porsche tycan
and they're going to fill it up at elon
musk's gas station
and if you don't think he's going to
make a buck on that you're not paying
attention
this is what i was talking about back in
2017. i said listen i think he's going
to have an
energy footprint that is envious of
people and they're going to be coming to
him
the issue is going to be as the number
of electric vehicles
increases out on the road this may not
be enough and it won't be
people still be charging at their home
and so they have announced that
2021 is going to be a crazy aggressive
year
for supercharger builds in the united
states making this footprint
denser and denser and then on one day it
won't matter what you buy because you'll
pull into the tesla gas station
to put those volts into your car okay
that's power thanks for watching the
short clip if you like that and like to
see the whole episode
you can find it right here and for even
more
subscribe to this channel right here
[Music]